so as we pick up with part four of the
DC vs. Marvel event we start out now
with a quick explanation on the amalgam
universe so because DC vs. Marvel was
selling like gangbusters when it came
out the both companies had the idea to
basically create a self-contained
universe and that's what happened at the
end of the last video you know when the
when the brothers merged with one
another and they created the amalgam
universe what Marvel in DC did is they
went back and they started creating
origins and they treated these
characters as if they'd existed all
along and so you know for example dark
claw is you know Logan Wayne it's a
combination of Batman and Wolverine and
they provided an origin for his
character you know they did this with
every single amalgam member the issue
here was that it was uh it was weird to
say the least and so almost immediately
after this amalgam universe forms ah it
gives us the opportunity to sort of go
back and to catch up on you know these
different variations of characters and
so on but the spectre and the Living
Tribunal both of the you know
second-in-command to their respective
God so to speak and in the Marvel and
the DC Universe end up merging with one
another and they were not really merging
but they end up working with one another
and they commune with access and access
uses his shard or uses his powers to
more or less cleave the amalgam universe
in half and set everything back to
normal and so this is we're not really
back to Noah but all the characters back
to the way they were before and so
instead of having you know spider boy
instead of having Ben Reilly and
Superboy Connor kin merged into a
singular being instead of having you
know dr. strange and dr. fate emerged
you know merged into a singular being we
instead get them back to their normal
selves and this is really where the
story begins to go off the rails and
what I mean by that is if it wasn't
crazy before it gets crazy now and it's
just one of those instances where Marvel
and DC kind of wrote themselves into a
hole you know with Batman and Captain
America and access working alongside one
another in an attempt to bring these
brothers down we're just kind of given
like a mishmash of nonsensical things we
have you know Superman and we have we
have the Incredible Hulk you know who go
against the Malloys and Mole Man they're
basically working together it's
essentially the superhero is trying to
deal with their own respect
villains and set everything back to
rights but it's also a living tribunal
and it's also the specter doing what
they can as well but in the end because
the power of these brothers are so
extreme they're basically sort of left
without any way to combat the situation
and so the result is Marvel and DC we
kind of handle it on their own and they
pit you know the brothers against one
another the argument here is that
because the brothers are so wildly
powerful they're the only ones that can
end the conflict and so once they start
fighting each other you know in the
midst of this battle they actually look
into the past of both Captain America
and Batman and when they realize why it
was that they became heroes when they
realized that Bruce Wayne became a hero
because his parents were murdered when
they realized that Captain America
became a hero to save the world from the
greatest threat you know from from the
Nazis the brothers this is then at best
the brothers are inspired by their
reason for becoming heroes and realized
that fighting among themselves is
pointless that they're best suited to
basically work together they achieve a
kind of inner peace and so what they end
up doing is is they effectively just you
know they shake hands but you know they
can graduate each other on on their own
in achievements basically saying yes you
know the Marvel brother has done some
great things and the DC brothers done
some great things they basically call it
a day and everybody goes back to their
own respective realities and in the end
access just kind of goes back into the
unknown
ah the ending is the ending of this is
is a perfect example of anticlimactic
it is not very good and this is one of
the most this is one of the things that
people are so disappointed about when it
comes to the mall you know the DC versus
Marvel crossover is it was a really cool
matchup until the end because I felt
like Marvel and DC didn't know how to in
this story they didn't know how to set
things back to rights but one thing I
also want to point out here is that in a
previous video something you guys have
mentioned I had said the Infinity
Gauntlet would come into play with with
Thanos and Darkseid that's actually in
the jla/avengers crossover which I was I
was so caught up in
the in our story after this point that I
actually totally forgot about that but
but any event um I know this video was
super short in comparison to the others
uh let me know what you guys think
because it you know it's it's not
terrible but the ending really just kind
of throws the entirety of the event off
kilter so so let me know what you guys
think again I know this was really short
but it's just best I could do with what
we had and yeah so I will catch you guys
with it peace
[Music]